i i would like now to pass her to
vaughter so he
introduced our let's last speaker for
today
thanks dimitra so three years ago dusk
enabled us at html
to make a start with scaling out our
existing pandas code
on our on-premise cluster and it proved
that to be really valuable for us
and made a case towards hml
that this uh is the way to go
and this led to a whole new group
starting at hml and i'm still part of
that group
so i'm happy about all the developments
going on at dusk
therefore i'm happy to introduce to you
metro rocklin
he is a long time open source developer
core maintainer of dusk and founder of
coiled
he will talk about dusk at global scale
with coiled
and the floor is yours yeah hi everyone
um thank you so much for the chance to
say hi i won't keep you from
um matt's talk i know um that's what
you're wanting to hear
but we just want to thank you for your
support of num focus and of the whole
um ecosystem we're um excited that this
is the second
online pi data event in the netherlands
um the first one was a big success and
this one looks like it is
following that path um i'd just like to
invite
everyone to learn more about the work
we're doing at numfocus
on our website you can tune in to
social media or subscribe to our
newsletter so
again thank you so much for helping us
with our mission to
support the projects that you use and
you're depending on
matt we'll let you take it and uh yeah
so hi everyone
my name is matt uh let me bring up my
slides here
i also put a link to the slides in the
discord
uh so hopefully you're now seeing a
coiled dash
everywhere so what about me my name is
matt
i'm a long time maintainer of various
open source projects
in the python space i mostly think about
parallel computing
mostly with a project called desk which
we'll talk about today
recently some of the dash maintainers
left and made a company we're trying to
make it easy to deploy dusk
this talk is to talk a little bit about
some of the motivations
uh for that mostly around solving sort
of my team needs that we saw
uh so this talk is sort of blend
non-profit for-profit open source
infrastructure topics uh so
um let's
so the context of this talk uh i usually
think of the context where we we want to
rapidly explore data and that's really
what pi data i think shines
at you have a bunch of information
that's being presented to you and you
want to derive some value from that
you might use numpy pandas scikit-learn
pi torch xgboost
jupiter plotting libraries et cetera to
do that
and hopefully that works out really well
for you sometimes the data that you were
given
is large or the competitions you want to
do are
time consuming so sometimes you want to
scale
this can be hard because programming
many computers
is harder than programming a single
computer uh oftentimes people who are
taught to do statistics
are not taught to do you know network
programming uh
it can also be hard because it's hard to
operate on computers that we don't
control ourselves this creates lots of
administrative issues
the first set of these problems
programming many computers is why we
made
desk das makes it easy to operate on
many computers at once
in a way that's hopefully comfortable
and familiar to you
uh what we found after many years of
using desk is that there was another set
of challenges these i.t
challenges and that's why we made coil
to solve the i.t challenges
so in this talk we'll talk first a
little bit about desk and what that
provides
they're talking about what we often see
in practice but why it's kind of hard to
use tools like desk
that'll give some motivation for coil
then hopefully at the end i'll say hey
there's a public service you can go use
which you might find interesting but our
goal here is to
make computing generally more accessible
and this could be
for people working in very large
companies have very intense id
constraints
or it could also be for individual
students who want to
you play around or learn a little bit
about parallel computing but don't
necessarily have access
to you know an i.t department or a
devops team
to help them set up those resources
so i'm going to switch to a quick
example
first so
let's try this
so i am on my laptop here on the left
i've got an ipython session open
and i'm going to connect to a cluster of
machines that i've allocated
uh beforehand and i might
let's run a simple computation let's
maybe make a function inc
which will import time and random
we'll sleep for a random amount of time
then return x plus one so this is just a
simple dummy function
that i could run you know locally on my
laptop
and that sleeps for some amount of time
and then returns a number
you might imagine this being you know
some other function that you're thinking
of you know load some data and maybe
train some data
and i'm moving on this you know a
thousand times
uh and so i can use dask to leverage
a bunch of machines that are somewhere
else
to do that work for me and we're seeing
that activity happen on the right
every little green rectangle that
appears on the right
is some some remote call of increment
and so now we have all of those results
so so desk is very much about
uh presenting the illusion that all of
these remote machines
are actually just kind of on my local on
my local machine
here i'm using sort of a very basic map
interface for desk there's lots of other
libraries that are built around desk for
example das is generation with pandas
so i'll go ahead and load up some data
that's sitting on
amazon s3 this is a new york city
taxicab data set
i think it's maybe 20 or 30 gigabytes in
of ram
you can see the memory increasing up
here in the upper upper right
and now we're loading that data again
not on my single machine but on many
machines that happen to be living
also on amazon and so we're getting this
again this experience
of using you know pandas-like
computations
uh but now that work is being spread out
to lots of other machines that are
living elsewhere
and in principle in theory
you know das should look very much like
apis that you're familiar using with
today in the sort of pi data ecosystem
uh but in practice there's a lot of
internals that are working to make it so
that
that's uh that's easy to do uh so we
might you know
compute maybe the the average trip
distance based on passenger count
and we find you know some result so
there's again lots of activity
happening here on the right for all
these distributed machines
but on the left we get to act like data
scientists
and write code that is hopefully
interpretable
to most people in the audience so that's
what das provides
uh let me switch back to slides for a
second
so let's talk about desks for a moment
and we'll get into
what was what was challenging to make
all that work smoothly
so dasc is a library it's python library
that was designed to scale other python
libraries in the pi data ecosystem
it works well on your laptop for
multi-core and larger than the memory
execution
so if you've got a 100 gigabytes of data
and you just want to sort of stream
through that on your laptop
it asks me a very good fit uh das is
also designed to operate on clusters and
machines so you have a thousand machines
you want some research scientific
cluster or on some kubernetes cluster or
on the cloud
to ask you leverage those machines and
that's what we that's what we just saw
uh das is easy to use uh we think it's
relatively lightweight
it's true python and that has led to a
lot of integration with other python
libraries
so again das was originally designed to
scale libraries like numpy pandas and
scikit-learn when we're making it we
thought you know
these libraries are good but they don't
scale very well
you can't use pandas on a terabyte of
data
and so we built variants of those
libraries
which which wrap around the existing
libraries so if you use task array
you're using many numpy arrays in
parallel if you use das data frame
using many pandas data frames in
parallel using dascml you're doing
some fancy machine learning stuff but
these libraries are very much
tightly coupled with their single
machine counterparts
in order to make those sort of uh
parallel numpy parallel pandas libraries
we end up having to build a dynamic
task scheduler so das works kind of in
these three stages
on the left we have you know pandas
light code or number light code
which is again hopefully interpretable
to you das
translates that into a task graph let me
actually switch back to our
demonstration here for a second
and maybe we can go and look at what
those graphs look like
so when i write something like this
group by computation
what's actually happening is that uh
das takes that computation it breaks it
down
into uh lots of little small tasks that
depend on each other
uh then you maybe didn't see it it was a
little bit too fast but then executes
all those little small tasks
on the on the various machines that we
have right so i've got here
you know 10 machines each with four
cores sitting on the cloud
and so what we found is that many
many users uh wanted this sort of graph
execution engine
but didn't necessarily want the the
pandas interface or the numpy interface
and so they they took just the graph
execution
and and ran with that instead so again
task is both a high level a set of high
level apis
and an internal low-level task scheduler
maybe sort of like the engine the task
is probably the engine of desk that
executes all these tasks in parallel on
different machines
it was as though we had built a fast car
and people said that's a really nice car
but i actually just want the engine and
that's because they were doing something
else
python people were building rockets or
roombas or
you know other devices
and so people in python tend to be very
creative and they have lots of different
needs
it's actually really hard for us as a
das community
to make high-level apis that would fit
all those different needs people had
lots of different
different constraints and that was
actually really exciting
and that has resulted in lots of
different libraries
adopting desk so if you use libraries
like numpy or pandas yes
i'd ask is iteration but also psychic
image
or xgboost or rapids or x-ray
or prefect there are many libraries that
are now integrating with basque
we're seeing some of those examples on
the right so here we're seeing
looking at ocean currents off the coast
of japan in real time
so this is the same scalability that we
would get with the parallel pandas
interface but now with a very different
kind of data
dasc is used in point-and-click
applications
like nepari a 3d image viewer uh so this
isn't targeting data scientists this is
targeting actual scientists
who are you know sitting at a lab bench
somewhere uh
projects like data shader for advanced
visualization use desk along with other
libraries like number
and so what we're seeing here is a
variety of different applications that
we did not anticipate
that are all powered by das which really
extend a lot of the reach the task is
full in real time
again projects like prefect or rapids
are also now sort of built on top of
desk which makes it really exciting
so we started with this application of
big pandas big numpy but we found that
the community took task in very
different directions from what we
anticipated
a lot of people built on top of it and
that's sort of where we see a lot of
desk growth today
so unfortunately
uh even though das had succeeded in
paralyzing
a lot of computations uh we still saw a
lot of
a lot of groups of individuals struggled
to adopt it
for reasons that had nothing to do with
parallel computing uh
if you wanted to use das today you might
look at our docs and you'd say great i'm
gonna go get some cloud account
i'll learn how kubernetes works uh i
need to figure out how to access my data
you know maybe i've got it in a private
s3 bucket how do i move around my
credentials
to all of my das workers or you know i
want to run some special library maybe
i'm using the
facebook profit library for example how
do i install that not on my local laptop
but on on a thousand computers in the
cloud
and so lots of other challenges that we
found people had to
had to figure out before they could get
the sort of the the easy experience
that we wanted people to have now the
sharp
people who could do this eventually
succeeded and everything was great and
they were very very happy for a while
um but generally speaking if you have
used dasc
on more than your laptop you've had to
answer some of these questions
and these questions end up not being
things that we teach you're sort of
average data scientist you don't sort of
learn how to use kubernetes
in your statistics course um so there's
other skill set that we found a lot of
people struggling with
additionally once people did succeed in
getting
these skills there were a different set
of concerns that showed that that
occurred
so you know things like they left their
cluster on
accidentally and were you know charged
ten thousand dollars to their company
accidentally
suddenly gets involved they say wait
what is this desk thing it's running on
our computers what's it doing
they learn that it's running arbitrary
python code across their network
and you know isn't secured by default
and they you know understandably have
some concerns
uh you know the manager is concerned a
little bit about how they're how we're
spending money
uh and so there's lots of other
challenges ended up arising
uh once you get past the sort of
uh early adopter uh stage
in a in a company or an academic setting
also we found that a lot of these sort
of early adopters
who are originally data scientists but
but end up becoming this it sort of i.t
data science hybrid they were spending a
lot more time
on their i.t work than they wanted to
and they wanted to get back to data
science they wanted to
remove the need of managing these
systems from themselves
and so in general das solved the
computational problems
but the organizational and i.t problems
still persisted
a good example of this is the pangeo
project
pangio is a collaboration of of earth
scientists who are doing things like
climate change
hydrology uh hydrol um coastal erosion
it's an international group and they
started off as lots of
earth scientists couple with some open
source developers and they made a really
awesome
stack with jupiter hub and
das and kubernetes in the cloud and it
was amazing we really changed i think
how
a lot of these climate scientists and
meteorologists do their work
but we found pretty quickly there were
all these other problems that we've
already sort of talked about
you know building docker images managing
data access
handling user quotas also things like
you know what if
maybe you have some group that's
managing the kubernetes cluster in the
united states
but you've got you know some eu uh
weather service
that wants to read their data and they
don't want to sort of always cross
the atlantic in in doing that data
transfer
or maybe their data isn't on aws maybe
it's on azure
um there are lots of other challenges
that we found
uh after sort of digging in a little bit
deeper
uh there are also a lot of social
concerns uh it was hard to find people
to keep things running
um just having you know a dedicated
uh devops person around ends up being a
pretty critical
uh part of a service like this this also
wasn't very
accessible for for smaller groups
smaller groups like individual
researchers or professors or students
and so we wanted to find some way of
replicating the pangeo stack
but that could be applied to lots of
other disciplines and lots of other
groups
so uh earlier this year a few das
maintainers
and some web developers made a small
company coiled
which our tagline is das for everyone
everywhere
uh and we are trying very hard to make
it as easy as possible
to solve those it and devops challenges
so that people can do all of this great
work with dasc on
data science machining workloads
uh so uh here's what i'd like to put on
my for-profit hat just for a moment
hopefully you guys don't don't mind
so coiled uh provides hosted desk it
manages software environments it manages
teams
uh it's fully secure it also runs from
anywhere
so it's designed to reduce i t barriers
uh
we've tried very very hard it's the
lower right of this screen there's a pip
install command and then two
python commands and if you run those
you'll get a dash cluster on amazon
you'll be asked to authenticate with
github or google and provide some some
token
but anybody if you want to can run this
now and it's
free to use and relatively easy that's
also what i was
using when i first started
my talk here let's go up to the very top
so on my laptop i asked for a cluster of
10 machines
and that's how i started so you can
actually do everything that i did here
uh in the next couple of minutes if
you're interested in doing that
um let's see i've got around five
minutes left
i'm gonna i think skip some examples
what i will do
is i'm going to point you to
docs.coil.io
which has some examples that you can run
pretty comfortably
and again this is maybe a good uh a good
way of playing around
you know so i was going to show you uh
scaling xg boost and if you want to you
can
go launch a notebook and play around in
a minute or two i was also going to show
you
prefect which is intentionally not a
notebook prefect
is like a like an airflow uh alternative
uh there's a script here you can run
which will you know run some small job
for you
by integrating with innovative prefab so
this shows you how you can use
dask and coiled to scale up lots of
popular libraries again like actually
boost prefect by torch etc
but now maybe a little bit easier
because you don't have to figure out how
kubernetes works or how the cloud works
so let's dive in a little bit into how
coils solve these problems in particular
um
and actually i'm going to switch back to
demonstration just for a second
and there's a lot of things that
happened here that i want to sort of
call your attention to
so when i asked for a cluster
some service went off and allocated a
bunch of machines for me in the cloud
then it set up security on those
machines it installed software on those
machines so
things like pandas were available on
those machines for me
or libraries to read from s3
and then it secured it and gave me
access to that so a lot of a lot of
magic happened in these two lines
uh second you know when i'm accessing
this data on on s3 i actually need to be
credentialized to access this data
amazon will not let just anybody access
it they need to know that you're a
person who has an amazon account
and so coiled got my local credentials
for them in a very secure way to my
remote workers
uh and made those workers look like me
so you know passing on authentication
is really critical um
also if i try to do something like i try
to you know scale my cluster out to a
thousand
thousand workers you know cold is going
to say no
your account uh can't use that amount of
amount of work
you're already using 42 cores your
account is limited to 200.
uh sorry you know i can't give you four
thousand four thousand works
so these are the sorts of um
capabilities that are happening in the
background that ended up being
pretty critical so i'm just going to
blast through a few of these in the next
few minutes so
coil runs on aws currently we're
launching azure in the next
probably a month or so and it runs on
any region
uh on any account so you can provide
your own aws credentials if you work in
a
in a more secure environment or you can
use ours um
it runs on 980 region so anywhere aws
runs we run
uh we run sort of at full scale
coiled build software for you sends this
was a
really common challenge we found with
the pangea community
is that every different scientist had a
different set of libraries that they
wanted to use
and so rather than us managing and
building docker images for them
as it being very very helpful to give
everybody
the capability of making these things
themselves even if they don't know how
docker works
additionally having some shareability of
those software environments ends up
being really important
what we found often is that um
groups like team leads like professors
would often
make a software environment for their
group and then want to share that among
their group
and so having some basic sharing ability
ends up being pretty critical
uh one of the things we really cared
about when making coiled was not forcing
people
into our development environment if you
look at competitors like data bricks you
sort of always have to use data breaks
inside of databricks notebooks
i turn to the python people tend to use
ides sometimes like vs code or pycharm
or they use you know things that are not
notebooks we saw in the video
earlier uh napari uh an image viewer
and that's that's not a notebook
application that's actually like a rich
client application that has to be run on
a desktop
and so we wanted coil to run to be able
to run from anywhere
and so in our demonstration uh
i'm running this from a local ipython
session i could have run this from a
local jupyter notebook
i could have used a notebook in the
cloud i could have used some other
notebook service like sagemaker
and so coil is very much intentionally
decoupled from from where you run your
your execution uh we're doing this
intentionally because we found it very
difficult
to try to
to fully encapsulate everyone's
development environment it ends up being
tricky everyone has their own
preferences for how to build their own
workspace cost management we saw this
before
coil manages costs we track every cpu
second everyone runs
and that allows people who are
controlling budget to be able to specify
different
policies which also ends up being useful
when you are
supporting a lot of sort of novice users
uh that might
leave clusters on for a long time or
might use jeep might ask for gpus but
not use them
so having those sorts of policies in
place ends up being uh very useful
uh coil can launch gpus by defaults it
also critically includes a lot of
pre-configured software environments
uh configuring gpu software environments
ends up being very hard
and so if you want to try out some of
the newer libraries like rapids
or pytorch or actually boost gpu
accelerated
coil is an easy place to do that
experimentation i gave a talk actually i
think just yesterday
at nvidia gtc or sort of talk about
using coil to switch back and forth
between cpu and gpu architectures
with the same code um
[Music]
cole is fully secure so again you can
run things inside of your own account
uh we do network security and we're
doing all the same best practices you'd
expect data is stored at rest in an
encrypted way so
i'll finish up here task and coiled
are trying to let us pretend that our
cluster is like a laptop
we're trying very much to replicate
that same experience of working locally
but on many machines
that's a lie you definitely need to
understand how
distributed computing works in order to
be fully efficient
but we're getting a lot closer and we're
working really hard to remove some of
those barriers
again das solves a lot of the
programming challenges a lot of the
algorithmic challenges
and coiled we're now trying to solve a
lot of the i.t or organizational
challenges
so uh that's it if you want to learn
more
i recommend das.org for information
around desk
uh coil.io for information about coiled
and if you're interested in trying out
all of this stuff uh
everything i've done here is publicly
accessible
if you pip install coiled and then
create a cloth cluster
it'll be ready to go so that's it
thank you everyone for your time and i'm
open for questions
yeah thanks for this talk about these
developments around dusk
we have a question from ruben mark
besides the non-computing challenges
what are still open challenges
in the computing field for dusk what are
operations
applications and algorithms that are
still hard to learn
when compute distributed
yeah i mean there's um there's like a
technical answer to that
which is there's lots of there's lots of
operations which is hard to paralyze
you know simple one might be something
like median for example
it's hard to compute the median in
parallel uh there's alternatives like
approximate quantile
but there's lots of lots of other ones
are just hard to do
uh i would say i'm going to answer that
question something differently
and say that there's a social challenge
i think right now what we're seeing
is many groups um adopt
desk but desk ends up being not the
right library for
you know a climate scientist to use for
example and so what we see is a lot of
other libraries building apis and a lot
of functionality around
desk and that's i think where we're
seeing a lot of growth and so
libraries like maybe x-ray and pangea
done a good job to translate dasc for
a certain set of scientific or business
users
and we're seeing a lot of maybe
horizontal growth so for example right
now in life sciences
there's a lot of packages which are now
starting to build desk support
so i think the next step
in sort of expanding use is not about
solving harder algorithms
it's just in solving more cultural or
community challenges
which often is done with people at the
pi data community
building libraries around desk or
integrating desks into their libraries
okay thanks we have another question
from axia
apart from bringing dusk to cloud what
unique features
do you have that's different from data
breaks and how much do you plan on
servers full of
philosophies in future or do you still
want your customers
to maintain their clusters on cloud
yeah that's a good question um in
regards to databricks the main
differentiation i think is just that
it's based around dusk
so most people who are using coil today
like dasc
they want something kind of like
databricks on the cloud and so coil ends
up being a nice
nice fit i think the sort of separation
of running coils not necessarily in
database notebooks opens up lots of
other possibilities
uh that ends up making it a little bit
more easy to integrate i think databrick
sort of tries to own
your world and coil is just sort of
solving one problem
of solving uh distributed computing at
scale
in terms of serverless uh yeah so that's
i mean so let's people have people mean
different things when they say server
lists
but here they're asking for a cluster
in this cluster i'm asking for a number
of workers so i'm like i'm bringing in
some concept of what a server is
but i'm not thinking about how to
allocate or provision servers
uh additionally you may notice the
warning here this takes about a minute
and so it's about a minute spin up time
about a minute delay whenever i want to
add or remove machines
this is about as fast as we can make
things without making it more expensive
but there are things that we could do to
give you
uh you know machines on the fly where
you stop thinking about it it would just
be a bit more expensive and we're sort
of playing with that a little bit
um systems like lambda which maybe the
more like traditional serverless
approach
end up being awkward for two reasons one
they're much more expensive
london has like a like a 10x costs boost
over spot and sizes
on aws uh also systems like lambda don't
handle
um internode communication
so this graph on the right some of these
tasks require
information from other tasks and systems
like lambda sort of don't manage state
well enough
so they're not not appropriate for a lot
of data science workloads
uh hopefully in the future we do find
some system that lets us do that but
we're not there yet
okay thanks there are two more questions
but due to time
we will put them in discord
uh then this the end of today right
uh so thank you thank you for listening
in uh
and see you tomorrow or the day after
thanks for having me everyone bye